All of this kind of induces a tree,
right?
You start in some state, there
are several actions you could take,
which gets you to another set of states,
and so on and so forth.
And this tree really, really,
really, really kind of builds up.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And you have a whole bunch,
in fact, a hyper exponential number,
of possible stories.
Well, if I have a probability
distribution for
all partial trajectories,
then it turns out that
whatever state I happen to be in
right now, let's say this one,
I don't actually have to care
about any of the rest of the tree.
It doesn't matter because
I can't get there.
See as you pointed out, it's cyclical.
So, even though I can get from
one plot point to another,
I can't see a sequence that
doesn't involve going this way.
>> Sure.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, that's right,
but underneath that node,
there's still an awful
lot of other nodes.
>> But if I have a probability
distribution for all of the next
states I could get to, then I
simply have to execute the action.
And then I will end up in
one of these states, and
when I do, it doesn't matter
what the other ones were.
And so all that's ever happening
is that I am following
one particular path down the tree.
>> And how do we get from that target
distribution that kind of specifies
the goal, to a target distribution over
all the intermediate nodes of the tree.
>> Right, that's the hard part.
>> Okay.
>> But it turns out there are easy
answers to it.
>> Okay.
>> I'm just not going to
tell you what they are.
>> Cool and have you used this for
actually making stories?
>> Yeah, we actually done this for
making stories and
actually shown that you
can get people to feel
satisfied in their stories or
experiences that they're having.
And you can do it in real-time,
on the fly and and I'll just leave
you with this little teaser.
It involves using Kubrick live or
diversions.
>> [LAUGH] Is not exactly
the most exciting teaser.
I thought you we're going to say
something about wolves again.
>> Well in the end that's all a wolf is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I would love to talk about it, but
I think it's probably beyond
the scope of the class.
But we'll put in the resources link
a series of papers that talk about this.
But the real answer is that, any time
you're trying to match probability
distributions, you care
about KL divergence.
And KL divergence is just a bunch
of sums of probabilities, and
sums mean linear independence.
Independence means I can
do them in any order.
So I can basically just ignore all the
things that I don't actually see, and
I only ever see a finite and
not just finite but
linear in the number of plot
points at any given time.
And the hard part is as you recognize
is figuring out what probability
distributions are for
the intermediate node.
I mean that can be very hard because it
can require computing the whole hyper
exponential tree.
Or can be very easy if you have
a nice function that can map
partial trajectories into probabilities
or some other kind of value.
>> Cool, okay.